mais me
j'arrive pas à croire que tu danseras
pas avec nous cette année je dois me
concentrer sur harvard il ya une vidéo
circulant sur le net qui montre une
soeur des sigma beckham et à s'envoyer
en l'air dans leur jardin
il faut donner aux sbb une image
positive de filles contribuant à la
communauté vous n'avez pas une grande
compétition gâteau ce truc de ce thème
de bienfaisance in juste ou pas leur
apprendre ma communauté à me renier vous
fait oublier cette débâcle des sbds vous
garantit votre admission à harvard
non je crois savoir comment sauver votre
chapitre et être réhabilité participer à
un stade chaud de bienfaisance de
grandes danseuses de country
ça surprend personne le stepping
requiert une rigueur et une discipline
implacable on ne boit pansements et
presse ont parfaitement us clés comme le
reste de mon corps
il faut que je voie le boulot que j'ai à
peine c'est bon j'en ai assez vu tu les
entraîne pas déjà tu es folle si mes
soeurs découvre que je vous entraîne au
stepping on va se bouffer le nez comme
dans une télé-réalité version hip hop
j'adore quand ça se cache dans les télé
réalités blanche est ce que vous avez
entendu s'ils ne peuvent pas travailler
en équipe
on est dans la merde sur quoi elle a
trébuché sa vie qu'elle est sérieuse les
soeurs chocolat comment vous voulez
qu'on vous respecte alors que vous ne
vous respectez pas les unes les autres
vous êtes une vraie sororité qu'il ne
faut pas sous-estimer moi je dis
carrément la solidarité entre soeurs est
votre lien ne le laissez pas se briser
vous sentez pas votre place comme si on
vous juger avant même que vous puissiez
vous exprimer
vous serez à leur place pendant quelques
minutes
vous allez perdre et chialeuse blanche
et vous noyé dans une piscine de larmes
ou leur montrer ce que vous avez dans le
ventre
je suis des caps à côté de chez vous
vous fait trembler notre maison on a
perdu toute une collection de verres à
chocques irremplaçable